now this is what's known as long-form
programming translation we actually have
a discussion with you that's difficult
for some people in the age of Twitter
and Facebook where everyone is
reactionary and and it's interesting to
me I'm getting old I can tell because
now I've seen several versions of the
English language come through in my
lifetime I was thinking about this
earlier because Twitter has its own
little version of language just saying
I'm just saying by the way I'm just
saying in my humble opinion that's not
really humble just saying it's like you
can insult correct you could say you are
ugly and your mother's ugly just saying
and if you put just saying after it
that's not supposed to be insulting then
see it's an it's a different form of
language that we use now and but I
remember it wasn't that long ago we at
the Valley Girls you remember the Valley
Girls okay okay okay you remember the
valley girls okay okay okay I thought
when Rachel was about that age I almost
wanted to knock her in the next week if
I told you if you say okay one more time
I'm gonna unjoin your head from your
body I cannot stand that anymore okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay oh my god
okay you remember that that was just 20
minutes ago but now it's just saying and
by the way the other interesting thing
on social media I love social be I've
had so much fun with it because some of
you people actually think you can have
an entire thought in 140 characters
which proves you have no ability to do
critical thinking by the way and and I
even read entire blogs where they can't
get an entire thought out you know with
critical thought that actually works
through the whole problem it's very
interesting out there and course social
media is given power to I mean I read a
blog earlier in the week it was a guy
who's a senior in college which is
wonderful I'm glad he's blogging but
listen if your senior in college I got
socks older than you I really don't care
what you think
really I do I mean I if that's insulting
to you go listen to something else I'm
sorry I like you I'll help you I love
you I'll do anything I can for you but
you're great political pontification
about whatever yeah I got socks older
news shut up we don't care what you
think that's this is what's interesting
about social media is it's given voice
to morons
it really has everybody's got an opinion
and everybody thinks their opinion
matters if you've never done anything
your opinion that's not matter we don't
care what you think be like asking my
opinion about brain surgery I've never
done it you don't need my opinion about
brain surgery I've never done it you
don't need my opinion about how to fix a
Ferrari I'm not even sure I can drive
one I sure couldn't fix one so my
opinion would be useless I'm a [ __ ]
about Ferraris they're kind of nice I
like looking at I don't want my car guy
but you know what I'm saying so you know
me doing a blog on Ferrari is like a 17
year old kid doing a blog about life he
hasn't had one yet I'm sorry dude if
that insults you go ahead and write your
blog it's fine but if we don't if we
discount your opinion as being stupid
because it is welcome to social media
something to think about guys because we
what we're doing here is we're really
giving voice to a bunch of people who
have not lived enough life to have a
voice where do you get wisdom from where
are you getting wisdom from it really is
your political party giving you your
sound bite talking points I mean if
you're a conservative does that mean
everyone everyone is you know lazy
except you is that what that means
doesn't mean that to me but I get
accused of saying that never said that
in my life I have met lazy people I have
met people who are fully injected with
hound dog blood lay on the porch in the
Sun lazy I have met those people but
there's not many of them and if you're a
liberal does that mean that you're a
victim as your political talking points
you never better be thinking about
what's your what CNN is feeding you
liberals and what Fox is feeding you
conservatives have you had an original
thought lately that you didn't get off
the TV see that's what long-form
programming is that's different than
sound bites now we have written
some of our advice to soundbites because
it's very effective and it works and the
advice is well thought out and has a
proven track record and so I'm still
will go with the debt snowball and the
baby steps that won't be changing this
hour because they work and it's
soundbite it up but it is interesting to
me that that you know if you here's
listen on Twitter Dave you should never
talk politics translation I don't agree
with your politics Dave I loved your
rant from the guys negative tweet the
negative email translation you agreed
with me and my value system Dave you're
thin-skinned and prickly translation I'm
a liberal and I can't stand anything you
say this is what it's very interesting
and something I don't mind if you're
liberal or conservative it doesn't
matter to me I don't care I'll be your
friend either way and I'm gonna help you
with your money either way so don't get
all mad and get your tail on the to it
twist say I won't do any good
and if you want to it's okay just go
listen to something else it's okay I'll
live through it it's fine we're doing
fine but it is amazing the lack of
thought people don't think they just
live they don't think data I mean if you
actually thought if you actually sat
down and contemplated things would you
ever text while putting on makeup while
eating while driving no thinking person
would do that and yet there are plenty
of quote-unquote intelligent people that
aren't wise enough to know that putting
those four activities together you got a
better chance of making it after
drinking about a keg of beer than doing
those four things at the same time
you're not gonna make it home either way
you're gonna find a ditch or find the
back end of mine well-insured car thank
you very much texting putting on your
makeup eating and driving all at the
same time and you're in the left lane
get over you're in the way for those of
us who are actually still driving 45
miles an hour down that freakin
interstate
nobody and you're in the left lane gee
try me nuts
people from Texas am i right you guys
get out there there's big open you can
do a run it's you've got a few places in
Tennessee like that but in the middle of
nowhere
and you're sitting in the left lane
going 45 miles an hour what is wrong
with you people thinking thinking
thinking is a good thing you see nobody
would intentionally go hey let's go
fifty-two thousand dollars in credit
card debt that would be intelligent
that'll help our marriage that'll help
our future people don't sit down and
make that out as their plan they just
don't think and when you don't think
you're going to the mall at Christmas
without a budget with no plan and guess
who has a plan the freaking malls got a
plan it's get your money and they're
good at it they will take your money and
you will have no money and you'll be
another four thousand dollars in credit
card debt and you'll look up after ten
years you got fifty two thousand dollars
in credit card debt and go crap how did
we do this cuz you weren't thinking I do
it too it's an interesting culture we
live in now if you want some help
thinking about your Christmas budget go
to my Christmas budget calm it's an
online tool it's free we're gonna
furnish it to you that's by the way case
you didn't know Christmas is December
25th this year sneaks up on people like
they move it or something thinking is
required this is the Dave Ramsey show
you